before machine made plate glass became
popular in the 1920s window glass was
blown by artisans
today specialty companies still make
window glass the traditional way while
machine made glass is uniformly clear
and flat mouth-blown window glass has
subtle variations
this german company produces a wide
variety of mouth-blown sheet glass
it's used to make contemporary wall
light panels it can also be used to make
clear or stained glass windows
the company can make glass sheets in 5
000 different colors and textures
[Music]
this furnace melts silica sand and other
natural materials into glass
the starter begins by inserting the end
of a blow pipe into a furnace
he takes a small amount of colorless
molten glass out of the furnace
and rotates it in a wooden mold the mold
is lined with heavy paper to soften the
surface
betty inserts a metal needle through the
blow pipe to create a pathway for air
he returns to the furnace for more
molten glass
the artisans make multiple trips to the
furnace shaping the molten glass in
stages so it's easier to handle
[Music]
this time the assistant shapes the glass
with a large mold
[Music]
when the shape is set the assistant
prepares it for blowing he uses a fork
tool to push the glass to the top of the
pipe
the starter rotates the glass in a
larger paper lined mold to round it
further
the molten glass cools rapidly once it
comes out of the furnace
if the temperature dips below 1800
degrees it's no longer workable so the
team must work quickly and reheat the
glass repeatedly
another assistant lubricates the blow
pipe so it will rotate easily on the
support stand
the starter hands the glass over to the
master glass blower
first he rotates the blowpipe to
straighten and center the drooping glass
then he begins turning and glowing into
the pipe to gradually inflate the glass
this requires great physical strength as
well as tremendous artistic and
technical skill
the pipe and glass weigh over 30 pounds
combined
when the glass starts to cool
the assistant reheats it in a smaller
oven he passes the pipe back to the
glass blower who then resumes inflating
it
this time he swings it upside down using
gravity to help elongate the shape
next he will transform the glass balloon
into a cylinder
first he reheats the tip of the glass
and weakens it with the hot burner
[Music]
then he reheats the entire glass
cylinder
this expands the air inside and forces
the weakened tip open
the glass blower taps the opposite side
of the hot glass with a cold metal stick
the thermal shock causes a neat stress
break
this releases the glass from the
blowpipe
then the assistant slices it lengthwise
with the glass cutter
and hands it off to the flattening team
their job is to transform this cylinder
into sheet glass
the flattening master's assistant puts
the cylinder into a furnace
it's heated to over 1500 degrees
[Music]
the glass softens in about 30 minutes
then the flattening master reaches into
the opposite end of the furnace with the
stick and gently opens the cylinder
next the flattening master irons the
glass sheet with a special wooden tool
the flat sheet goes into the annealing
oven for a gradual controlled cooldown
this relieves stress and prevents
cracking
the flattening masters assistant removes
the glass from the annealing oven and
performs a visual inspection
[Music]
the last step is to cut the edges
straight
to make multi-colored and textured glass
they add additional ingredients during
the melting process
[Music]
mouth blown window glass contains
natural variations that play with the
light and create a subtle blow
a glow that machine made window glass
can't replicate